on the one side the relative clear of
the Tasman Sea on the other the fire
zone this is the only way to get to
mallacoota a four hour boat ride along
this fire scarred Shore this is a lull
in the weather but the fires still tower
overhead a curtain of smoke drawn across
the entire coast the sea dark with ash
hillsides stripped the fires burned all
the way to the water aircraft going
around them this is a big worry a
headless afternoon outside mallacoota
Navy ships arrived today to deliver
water fuel and supplies
and rescued the first of the evacuees
everything's gone
this was mallacoota at the start of the
week a hell four thousand people forced
to shelter on the shore
and this is what the bushfire reads more
than a hundred homes are thought to be
lost it was a miracle no one died
there's no power and the roads out will
be blocked for weeks just take a look at
what's left of this vehicle it gives you
an idea of the scale of the fire we
spoke to one of the people fighting that
fire he's been in several faster ones
before he said this fire was the most
energetic most intense flames you'd ever
seen you can see what they've done this
is why four thousand people ran from
here they ran to the beach they ran into
the water to escape the flames this
house utterly destroyed all that's left
is the roof twisted corrugated iron on
the top and this has happened across
town more than a hundred homes destroyed
it is utterly devastated every now and
then I just feel nauseous at the thought
of what's happened and at the recovery
effort that's got to happen here I just
can't even imagine trying to rebuild
this town with all of these houses lost
it's going to be really hard for people
but it's an incredible community here
Angela and her family have registered
for evacuation her parents will go by
boat she and her toddler will have to be
airlifted that huge operation will begin
tomorrow the aim is to rescue a thousand
people
this was one of the shelters during the
firestorm now the town gathered to hear
the plan hey max tools have been
deployed to really have hundreds of
people over the coming days complaining
is that we can take up to 1,000 people
per voyage it's plain the itemized tools
and they take two or three voyages over
the coming days this is where they
register
they'll be ferried by small boats from
the jetty to a large Navy ship before
making a 20-hour voyage south to safety
all the while the fires here have never
stopped burning Tom Cheshire Sky News
mallacoota well the Prime Minister
visited the village of Kabongo in New
South Wales today but was met with anger
by residents there let's have a listen
to the exchange as a flood or a fire we
get nothing if we were Sydney if we were
North Coast we would be flooded with
donations with edge emergency relief
welcome well I'm not surprised people
are feeling very war at the moment and
that's why I came to
to be here to see it for myself to offer
what comfort I could but you can always
at all in every circumstance I think
everyone understands that I appreciate
their over welcome we received Jenni and
I but at the same time I understand that
very strong feelings people have that
they've lost everything and there is
still you know some very dangerous days
ahead you know this isn't about as I
said me or anyone else it's about what
is needed here on the ground I
understand people are feeling very very
warm and that's been on display here and
that doesn't surprise me